this isn't a zombie show and I know
there's a zombie on screen but the last
of us is really a show about humans
even so it'll probably make the zombie
genre explode all over again and give
new life to the corpse that is zombie TV
over the past several years we've been
inundated with zombie TV shows and
movies that all look and feel kind of
the same and now we have this so don't
be fooled by the zombie aspect of the
show The Last of Us is so much more than
that it's a story about love loss and
the things we do for the people we care
about so it's not a zombie show it's a
story about The Human Condition and it
has the potential to move and Inspire
audiences in a way that few other shows
can